(dramatic music)
(crowd shouts in foreign language)
(protester shouts in foreign language)
- [Dov] From blocking highways
to forming human chains
and dressing up as characters
from Margaret Atwood's dystopian novel,
"The Handmaid's Tale."
(protesters singing in foreign language)
- [Dov] For three months, up
to half a million Israelis
have taken to the streets
across the country
to protest a judicial overhaul planned
by Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu's government.
The growing revolt piled
pressure on Netanyahu
to suspend the overhaul
until parliament reconvenes
at the end of April.
(Benjamin speaks in foreign language)
- Here's what happening in Israel,
the stakes behind Netanyahu's
judicial overhaul,
and where things could be headed next.
(tense music)
There are many layers to it,
but there are three things
you need to understand.
First is changing the
committee that appoints judges.
This overhaul will give the
ruling coalition a majority
on that committee and that will allow them
to place like-minded judges on the bench.
The second pillar of the judicial overhaul
is to limit the jurisdiction of the court.
That means what cases will
the court be able to hear?
And the third thing, and perhaps
the most controversial bit,
is what's called the Override Clause.
That will allow a simple
majority of parliament,
meaning 61 of 120 lawmakers,
to override decisions
of the Supreme Court.
Netanyahu and his collation partners
say this judicial overhaul is necessary
in order to balance out the court.
They say that the court
is dominated by liberals
and that it's way too activist,
the court itself needs
a check on its power
because it is a essentially
blocking the will of the people.
For people who oppose the overhaul,
they believe it will undermine
the Supreme Court completely.
- Well, we came here to
protest against the degradation
of the Israeli democracy.
We see a process where
the rights of the people
will be overtime consumed by
this theocratic government.
- These protests have really exposed
long-held divisions in Israeli society
between its secular side
and its religious, more conservative side.
(tense music continues)
One of the major problems of this overhaul
for the protesters is
that it's being advanced
by Prime Minister Netanyahu himself.
Netanyahu has long been
a defender of the Court
and they ask themselves, "Why is Netanyahu
suddenly supporting this
massive judicial overhaul?"
And for them, the answer is clear.
It's because Benjamin Netanyahu
is on trial for corruption,
and if this overhaul passes
they believe he will use it
in order to get out of
his own legal problems.
Netanyahu denies this,
but the protesters at this
point simply do not believe him.
(protesters singing in foreign language)
(whistle blaring)
(protesters shouting)
- After Netanyahu has paused legislation,
it will be very, very
difficult for the opposition
and ruling coalition to find
an agreement on this issue
because they are so
far apart as it stands.
Perhaps the opposition and the coalition
will find a compromise,
but if they don't we can expect
this conflict to come back
and to come back stronger.
(machinery whirs)
(intense music)